Apollo 13 that is about many things it's
about this journey into space it's about
how hard you have to train to be an
astronaut but it's also about a
Brotherhood between these astronauts
they wouldn't have survived it this
Brotherhood between them wasn't working
first it was hard to pitch that story
cuz the studio executive say well
everybody knows they made it back safely
and I said but it's about a Brotherhood
and don't we all root for Brotherhood
hoods don't we all root for family it
sort of took the executive by surprise
because I didn't even want to argue the
story or the ending I just wanted to
case build on the Brotherhood because
Brotherhood is one might argue that's
what we're missing today in America